Speaker 1: Donald Trump will be arrested tomorrow.
He will surrender in New York City.
He will appear in court, presumably to enter
a plea of not guilty.
At which point he is expected to leave New
York City, fly back to Florida and hold what
will certainly be an unhinged press conference
at Mar a Lago shortly after 8 p.m. Eastern
time.
We're going to be covering all of it live.
We will be live tomorrow with the arraignment
and we will be live tomorrow with the press
conference.
That is essentially all I can tell you at
this time, because there are so many unknowns
at this point.
One of those unknowns is whether the arraignment
will be televised.
I'm going to separate that question out just
for a moment, because it's really its own
question.
And we will talk a little bit about what is
to be expected tomorrow.
The latest news is that Trump will fly from
Florida to New York today, Monday.
And even though the arraignment is scheduled
for 215 tomorrow, there are reports that Trump
will be at the courthouse early in the morning.
Why isn't exactly clear.
Certainly fingerprints, potentially a mug
shot, not expected to be handcuffed based
on everything we know right now.
But that doesn't take that long.
Is it because of security considerations?
Well, maybe.
There's numerous reports that New York plans
to close key streets for Trump's arraignment.
Patricia HURTADO from Bloomberg News reporting
that.
And that the entire area surrounding the Manhattan
courthouse is going to be closed down to vehicle
traffic.
It is also known that there are tunnels and
different ways to get to the main courthouse
building from surrounding buildings.
And for security reasons, presumably, Donald
Trump may be brought in through some kind
of secure this path.
It's not exactly completely clear.
We continue to learn more about what are the
charges.
Initially, we didn't know.
Then we knew that the number was over 30.
More recently, it's it's sort of focused in
on the number 34 questions about is it all
misdemeanors?
The latest report from CBS News is that there
are felony charges here.
So not only charges against Trump, not only
nearly three dozen charges against Trump in
this one of three or four major criminal investigations,
but felony charges as well.
At least one of them, CBS News, reporting
former President Donald Trump faces a felony
charge.
A source told CBS News Saturday.
A person familiar with the matter said to
CBS News.
Trump is being charged with falsifying business
records in the first degree, which is a felony
in New York state.
Now, immediately, the law and order people
coming out and saying it shouldn't be a felony.
This is part of the problem.
Screw that.
Well.
If you're for law and order right now, that's
a felony.
And if you are not above the law, if we have
justice, then everyone, regardless of their
position, job, wealth or situation of power,
would be subject to that law.
But how quickly the law and order people change
their tune when it is all of a sudden inconvenient.
There were concerns about violent protests
as a result of Trumpists showing up here or
there.
Now, I don't believe we are yet out of the
woods because there is a protest planned tomorrow
at noon in New York City involving repugnant
and radical reactionary Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
We will talk about that separately.
But the good news so far is that the protests
we've seen at Trump Tower in New York City
and at Mar a Lago have been pathetic.
A report from Bloomberg News is that at Mar
a Lago, few show up to protest Trump's indictment.
There were a dozen, maybe two dozen people,
quite pathetic.
And honestly, I'm glad.
I'm glad I don't want there to be violence.
And there was some video from New York City
where I think there was one pro tour, one.
It's not even a protest.
It's sort of like a show of support at Trump
Tower where there were one or two people,
not one or two dozen, one or two people, which
is absolutely hilarious.
Now, many of you have started to write to
me and said, David, you know, we know you're
going to be away in a little bit.
Are you?
What's the timeline of this Trump thing?
Are you going to be around to cover it?
The expectation is that, number one, these
things don't move that quickly.
And number two, you always want to delay,
delay, delay as much as you can.
There's an interesting article called Donald
Trump's Time Tested Legal Strategy Attack
and DeLay.
This article from D-N.Y.. U.S. says these
two tactics have been at the center of Donald
Trump's favored strategy in court cases for
much of his adult life and will likely be
the former president's approach to fighting
the criminal charges now leveled against him.
You want to delay as much as possible, and
many attorneys will tell you there are a whole
bunch of reasons for this.
You can delay with the hopes that those in
charge of prosecuting the case get frustrated,
change jobs, whatever you can delay and delay
and delay with the hopes that witnesses forget
their testimony or they die or whatever the
case may be.
It is often said by attorneys in many different
areas of criminal law.
The longer you can delay actually adjudicating
a case, the better.
And so none of listen to the fact that I'll
be away next week shouldn't at all impact
my ability to cover this, because we could
be talking about months if not if not years
potentially here.
And that is certainly to be expected.
I am not aware in terms of the defense that
this is all political, that this is all a
witch hunt, that these are merely political
decisions rather than legal decisions.
This is one of the main defenses we've heard
from people around Donald Trump.
I can't think of anyone that has used the
demand of political investigations more than
Donald Trump.
When Trump and his political allies say, Investigate
Hillary, lock up Hillary, lock up Hunter,
charge Joe Biden, etc., etc. absent any reason
to do so, it is they who have demanded the
political prosecution of their opponents.
And Trump is at the top of that.
So every time we hear this is all Alvin Bragg's
Soros politics, this that, the other thing.
Don't let your eye come away from the ball.
And the ball is all along.
Trump has been at the top of the list of those
who demand the political prosecution of his
opponents.
Let's now talk about the potential gag order
and the potential for Donald Trump to be re-arrested